[Musik]
weg mit den zentralbanken weg mit
unserem heutigen finanzsystem hin zur
vollen kontrolle über das eigene geld zu
einer gerechteren welt
dank digitaler währung so zeichnen
bitcoin enthusiasten ihre vision der
digitalen zukunft das neue geld besteht
aus computercodes bisher führte es ein
nischendasein in diesem jahr soll es nun
durchstarten digital währungen bieten
völlig neue möglichkeiten sagt
zukunftsforscher stephan sigrist ein
[Musik]
geldtransfer heute von bank zu bank
läuft die information über belastung
beim bezahl und gutschrift beim
empfänger
das dauert und kostet gebühren auch beim
e-banking eine digitale währung hingegen
wird blitzschnell verschickt per klick
und schon hatte empfänger sein geld in
form eines datenpakets in seinem
digitale portemonnaie
beinahe gebührenfrei banken start und
steueramt erfahren davon nichts
seit dem ersten januar akzeptiert die
schweizer niederlassung der
internationalen
wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaft ernst &
young die digitale währung in der
zentrale in zürich steht zudem einer der
ersten bitcoin automaten der schweiz die
funktionen franken and bitcoins tauschen
und umgekehrt
es sei an der zeit sich an die neue
technologien zu gewöhnen sagt ernst &
young ceo marcel schneider aktiv
die kehrseite der medaille
kriminelle geschäfte wie geld abpressen
betrug rücken handel
gauner lieben digitale transaktionen
denn sie sind kaum nachzuverfolgen
kaprun spezialist für
informationssicherheit an der eth in
zürich warnt vor einem naiven einsatz
der neuen währungen
es ist im prinzip so als würde man sein
geld einem maskierten mann auf der
straße geben
das heißt die zahlung ist völlig anonym
und sie kann nicht zurückverfolgt werden
und wenn man eine laufende transaktion
abbrechen möchte ist das nicht möglich
dabei soll die technologie auf der die
digitalen währungen basieren eigentlich
sicherer sein als das aktuell
gebräuchliche system
heute liegen unsere konto daten zentral
auf dem server einer bank bei digitalen
währungen liegen die informationen in
einem netzwerk sind auf tausenden von
rechnern gleichzeitig gespeichert und
werden permanent abgeglichen
jeder manipulationsversuch wird erkannt
und von den rechnern abgeblockt
kein lästiges bargeld mehr bezahlungen
mit einem klick ohne zwischengeschaltete
banken davon erhoffen sich die fans an
der bitcoin welt persönliche freiheit
[Musik]
das eine zeitenwende ansteht da ist sich
zukunftsforscher stephan sigrist sicher
sind 2017 wendepunkt vielleicht sei ja
vor große versprechen insbesondere
digitalisierung selbstfahrende autos
digitale bankensystem und ich glaube es
kommt jetzt der zeitpunkt wo man mit
notwendigkeit und ihr konkret wer in
alltags flüsse in konkrete
geschäftsmodell und alltag von menschen
digitale währungen könnten das heutige
geldsystem verdrängen
außer es kommt zum blackout